It’s the 1st of October, 1938.
Heston airport, just outside London.
A man steps out of a propeller airplane to
address a crowd of journalists, officials
and onlookers.
He waves in triumph a piece of paper carrying
two signatures, his and the one for a certain
Mr A. Hitler.
The man is hailed as a hero, as he announces
that he has truly achieved “peace for our
times”.
This man, whose status as a hero will soon
be critiqued by none other than Winston Churchill,
is the current British Prime Minister, Neville
Chamberlain.
He has just signed an agreement with the German
government, preventing war in Europe – at
least for the moment – but sacrificing the
young State of Czechoslovakia to Nazi demands.
Neville Chamberlain has become synonymous
with the ill-advised policy of Appeasement,
an emblem of the West weakness when faced
by the aggressive bullying of the Axis powers.
But is that fame fully deserved?
From Birmingham to the Bahamas
Arthur Neville Chamberlain was born in Birmingham,
England, on the 18th of March 1869, in a wealthy,
politically involved family, although they
were not part of the aristocracy.
His father Joseph was a Cabinet Minister during
Queen Victoria’s reign who had married twice
having a total of six children.
Beatrice and Austen, from a previous marriage,
and then Neville and three daughters, Ethel,
Ida and Hilda, from his second wife.
As it was tradition at that time, it was down
to the boys to perpetuate the trade and traditions
of the family.
Austen, Neville’s older half-brother, was
the one to initially carry out the political
ambitions of the Chamberlains.
He took up a string of civil service and political
posts, culminating his career as Foreign Secretary
in the 1920s.
He was the mastermind behind the Treaty of
Locarno between Great Britain, France, Weimar
Germany, Italy and Belgium which earned him
a Nobel Peace Prize.
Neville, on the other hand, was expected to
take the reins of the family’s many business
enterprises.
He perfected his education first at the Rugby
School and then at Mason College, now the
University of Birmingham.
Coming from a privileged family does not guarantee
happiness, though, and it was reported that
Neville was an introverted, shy boy, whose
school years were plagued by incidents of
bullying
After his formative years, aged only 21, Neville
was tasked by his father to manage one of
the Chamberlain’s business enterprises.
A daunting prospect for anyone, but the task
may have been made lighter by the fact that
the job involved managing a plantation.
In the Bahamas (ref BBC)!
That must have been fun for young Neville,
unfortunately after some years that business
venture ultimately failed.
Neville had anyhow proven himself to be a
talented manager and supervisor.
After returning to England he would put that
experience to successful use, first in the
private sector, and then following Austen’s
footsteps into politics.
Going into Public Service
In 1911 Neville Chamberlain secured his first
political post by winning a seat in the Birmingham
City Council.
In the same year he married Anne Vere Cole,
with whom he would later have two children,
Dorothy and Francis.
Chamberlain’s next step was to secure a
higher position in local politics, which he
did by becoming Lord Mayor of Birmingham in
1915.
By now aged 49, he was too old to serve in
WWI, but he did contribute to the war effort
as Director of the National Service, an appointment
awarded directly by Prime Minister Lloyd George.
This job involved ‘compulsion’, which
is basically the equivalent of conscription
for war industries.
However all of Chamberlain’s attempts to
drive compulsory labour into industries vital
to the war effort were hampered by the unions,
by the war cabinet or Lloyd George himself.
Apparently the two men could not stand each
other.
After Chamberlain finally resigned in August
1917, Lloyd George wrote to his family
“Chamberlain has resigned, and thank God
for that”
While Chamberlain referred to the Prime Minister
as
“that dirty little Welsh attorney”.
This experience almost deterred him to stay
clear of politics, but he made a comeback
into public life by winning a seat in the
House of Commons in 1918 as a member of the
Conservative Party.
From then on, his career was on the rise.
In 1922 he became Postmaster General in Andrew
Bonar Law’s government, a test that he passed
with flying colours, becoming Minister of
Health within months and, shortly afterwards,
Chancellor of the Exchequer.
All in little more than a year, and within
5 years of entering Parliament.
By the way, for those not familiar with the
workings of the British Government, the Chancellor
of the Exchequer is the Secretary or Minister
in charge of the Economy.
So, it is a big deal.
Chamberlain retained this post for the following
years, and did very well.
In 1929 he reformed the so called “Poor
Law”, which laid down the foundations of
the welfare state.
In the crisis that followed the Wall Street
Crash he protected the fragile state of British
industry by passing the Import Duties Bill,
in 1932.
All this hard work paid off when in May 1937
Neville Chamberlain was elected leader of
the Conservative Party and succeeded Stanley
Baldwin as Prime Minister.
His early efforts were a continuation of his
welfare reforms.
For example, the Factories Act of 1937 restricted
the number of hours that children and women
worked.
And in 1938 Chamberlain supported the Holiday
with Pay Act, which gave workers a week off
with pay.
By looking at his career so far you could
see how the shy boy from Rugby School had
turned into an active, ambitious leader willing
to bring about improvements to the society
around him by breaking up with established
traditions (ref BBC).
However, his achievements on the domestic
front were to be overshadowed by a looming
crisis in a faraway land, of which people
knew nothing about, to use his own words.
The Sudetenland Crisis
Right, I am not going to chart here the rise
of Hitler and the Nazi party and how the new
German government immediately started making
plans for territorial annexations.
I’ll actually tell you more about this later.
So, let’s scroll our Google maps south of
Berlin instead and look at the Sudetenland
region instead.
This is a region in then Czechoslovakia which
bordered with Germany and was home to some
3 Million ethnic Germans.
Back in 1931 a Sudeten German called Konrad
Henlein had founded the Sudeten Germans People
Party, which advocated for the region to secede
and be annexed to Germany.
Needless to say, in the following decade,
Nazi leadership had openly supported Henlein’s
cause.
Sure, Germans on both side of the Czechoslovak
border wanted to be reunited, but the push
for annexations had far more materialistic
reasons which worried the Government in Prague.
The Sudetenland region was home to lignite
and coal mines.
It was also the most heavily defended, meaning
a peaceful annexation to Germany would have
granted a convenient stepping stone to annex
the whole of Czechoslovakia.
Why would Nazi Germany be so interested in
absorbing that small, young, central European
state?
Skoda.
These guys now manufacture affordable city
cars, but back then the Skoda works were one
of the largest armament manufacturers in Europe.
The production volume of Skoda Works between
August 1938 and September 1939 alone was nearly
equal to that of all British arsenal factories
in that period.
And sorry to jump ahead, but in 1939 a certain
Hermann Goering made a nice little profit
by acquiring shares in Skoda.
So, I am going to venture a personal observation
and say that Nazi leadership main interest
was not the well-being of Konrad Heinlein
and the Sudeten Germans, but rather to replenish
their arsenals and their pockets.
But back to the crisis.
In late summer 1938 the Nazi party asked Heinlein
to stir some trouble, as a means to create
an excuse for a military intervention.
The government of Eduard Benes in Prague had
created a system of defensive alliance with
France and the Soviet Union, but neither of
them was really keen to intervene should an
invasion occur.
Chamberlain was well aware that if France
did intervene, also Britain would be dragged
into a European war, which not only himself,
but his whole cabinet and the majority of
the public opinion were keen to avoid at all
costs.
The British Prime Minister then took the initiative
to lead a series of negotiations throughout
September 1938 to prevent an armed conflict.
The first meeting with Hitler took place at
Berchtesgaden, near Munich.
At this meeting Hitler demanded that the Sudetenland
should be handed over to Germany.
Without consulting Eduard Benes, Chamberlain
agreed that those areas containing more than
50% Germans within them should be handed back
to Germany.
Chamberlain managed to get the Czechs and
the French to agree to this solution.
On September 22nd, Chamberlain flew again
to Germany, in Bad Godesberg to meet Hitler
so that the final details of the plan could
be worked out.
Hitler had a very low opinion of Chamberlain,
describing him in private as
“Ein Arschloch”
So it was not surprise that the Fuhrer stunned
the Prime Minister with a whole set of new
demands:
Number 1 - German troops were to occupy the
Sudetenland.
Number 2 - Czech lands containing a majority
of Poles and Hungarians should be returned
to Poland and Hungary.
Effectively, Hitler was demanding for a dissolution
of Czechoslovakia.
This time Chamberlain and French President
Daladier rejected these demands.
The stalemate was unblocked by Benito Mussolini.
He proposed an emergency conference in Munich
to reach an agreement once and for all.
The participants were
Germany [names of countries appear on screen
with a ping]
Great Britain
France
Italy
Can you spot the missing guest?
You are right: Czechoslovakia was not.
And neither was the Soviet Union, which pissed
off Joseph Stalin.
Without consulting the Czechs, the four powers
agreed that the Sudetenland should be given
to Germany immediately.
The governments of Britain and France made
it clear to the Czechs that if they rejected
this solution, they would have to fight Germany
by themselves.
This was the crowning moment of the policy
of Appeasement.
On October the 1st 1938, German troops occupied
the Sudetenland.
Polish and Hungarian troops also occupied
areas of Czechoslovakia which contained a
majority of Poles and Magyars.
The dismemberment of Czechoslovakia was complete
when Germany formally annexed what is today
the Czech Republic in March 1939, while Slovakia
seceded and became an Axis ally.
Let’s return now to our initial scene: Chamberlain
waving his newly signed agreement at the Heston
airport.
To him, a formal guarantee of “peace for
our time” in Europe.
To Hitler, just a
“scrap of paper”.
Did Chamberlain take the right decision?
It is easy to say, with the power of hindsight
that Chamberlain’s decision was a completely
wrong one.
On a moral level, the Western powers, as members
of the League of Nations and allied of Czechoslovakia
had a duty to step in and protect an allied
country – or other member States – from
aggressions and demands worthy of a schoolyard
bully.
On a practical level … the matter is more
complicated, but it also weighs against Chamberlain.
Now, the assumption that Britain and France
were not
ready
for
a full-scale war, especially with Germany,
may have been correct.
And it is understandable that Chamberlain
and Daladier were keen to avoid at all cost
another carnage like the one brought about
by WWI.
The British Prime Minister had a particular
fear of what destruction on civilian targets
could be caused by the new tactics of war
from the air.
It seems that upon returning from his first
flight to Munich, he observed how easy would
have been for a bomber to hit at the heart
of London.
One of his military advisers even told him
that two months of bombing raids would have
caused one million victims.
But.
But!
Germany itself was not yet ready for a war
with the West in the Autumn of 1938, the Wehrmacht
being much weaker than it appeared from Goebbels’
propaganda reels.
A full mechanization of the Heer, or land
forces, on the basis of General Guderian’s
doctrine were still on the horizon.
More importantly, the high echelons of the
armed forces were not a united front supporting
the Nazi party.
It is reported in fact that the Army Chief
of Staff, General Franz Halder was planning
to eliminate Hitler and even carried a loaded
gun with him at all times, should the occasion
arise.
In September and October of 1938 the German
High Command was fully aware of the country’s
relative weakness and did not welcome the
prospect of a war with Czechoslovakia, even
if Britain and France did not come to the
rescue.
Czechoslovakia may have been a small country,
but its army was well trained, well equipped
and well defended by fortifications.
Did Chamberlain know all this?
Apparently he did receive a report from MI5
detailing Halder’s plans, but would that
have been enough to change the opinion of
Chamberlain and of the majority of the Cabinet?
More importantly, would that have been enough
to change the course of eight years of Foreign
Policy dedicated to appeasement?
A brief history of Appeasement
Neville Chamberlain became synonymous with
Appeaser, but certainly he wasn’t the first
political leader, neither in Great Britain
nor elsewhere, to pursue a policy of appeasement
in the face of military threat and aggression.
Are you ready for a brief history of appeasement?
Let’s start then!
Round one – Japanese invasion of Manchuria.
In 1931 an explosion on the South Manchuria
railway gave the Japanese military the perfect
excuse to invade this Chinese region, to protect
Japanese interests in the area.
It was all part of a plan of aggression to
expand Tokyo’s sphere of influence, provide
an outlet for the booming population and provide
new markets for a struggling industrial sector.
The League of Nations’ intervention was
initially bent on economic sanctions, which
Britain and France did not endorse, fearsome
of losing trade with Japan or even provoking
a full-scale invasion of British colonies
in the Far East.
The result?
A weak plan to create a semi-independent state
in Manchuria, which Japan rejected by quitting
the League of Nations and going on to complete
the invasion of the region and establishing
the puppet state of Manchukuo.
Round two!
– Failed Anschluss attempt, 1934.
Not one year in power and Hitler and the Nazi
government were already bent on annexing Austria.
Their plans kicked off with an attempted coup
carried out by Austrian Nazis, which were
obviously funded and directed by Berlin.
The conspirators even managed to assassinate
Prime Minister Dollfuss and the German troops
were ready to move in.
The Western powers, again did not intervene.
Who, of all people, put an end to this first
go at Anschluss?
You may be surprised: Benito Mussolini, who
at this time was not yet allied to Germany
and was instead tied to Vienna by a protective
treaty.
Mussolini deployed two Alpine troops divisions
on the Austrian border and the still-weak
Wehrmacht had to hit the brakes.
Round three!
– Italy invades Ethiopia, 1935.
Yesterday, the defender, today the attacker:
a border incident with Ethiopia gave Mussolini
the excuse to order an invasion of Ethiopia
in October 1935.
British public opinion was in favour to intervene
against Fascist Italy.
It would have been dead easy: just shutting
down the Suez Canal to Italian shipping would
have put an end to the invasion.
But Prime Minister Baldwin did not want to
alienate Mussolini and his anti-German stance.
Any intervention was delegated to the League
of Nations.
While negotiations dragged on into 1936, the
Ethiopian capital Addis Ababa fell in May
1936.
Round four.
Hitler retakes the Rhineland, March 1936.
The Rhineland includes the border areas with
the Low Countries which were meant to stay
de-militarised as per the Treaty of Versailles.
But taking advantage of the Ethiopian crisis,
the Germany army just up and went!
They took a huge gamble, by the way.
The marching units carried rifles loaded with
blanks and had strict orders to retreat immediately
at the slightest sign of Franco-British resistance.
But resistance did not materialise, the occupation
was carried out and Germany gained a huge
advantage in preparation for the War to come.
Round six.
Japan invades the rest of China, 1937.
What started as minor clashes between the
Imperial Japanese Army and the Chinese nationalist
forces in July of that year quickly escalated
into a full-blown invasion.
As usual, the Western powers, the Soviet Union
and the League of Nations looked on, while
the Japanese carried out indiscriminate bombing
of civilian targets.
Interestingly, help for Chiang Kai-Shek’s
Chinese nationalist army came from Nazi Germany,
in the shape of training and supplies.
Round seven.
The successful Anschluss in March 1938.
When Germany incorporated Austria, the West
remained silent and Italy was now on the side
of the invader.
By now Chamberlain had replaced Baldwin as
Prime Minister, and as you may have guessed,
he simply continued with the same policy put
in practice by his predecessors and fellow
member states in the League of Nations.
In addition to the desire of avoiding a major
war on the continent, Chamberlain was also
motivated by “compensating” Germany in
some way for the harsh treatment imposed by
the Treaty of Versailles.
Moreover, one of the key principles of the
post-WWI world order was self-determination.
Based on that principle, wasn’t it lawful
to allow German minorities to reunite with
their motherland?
And now for the …
Bonus round!
– The Spanish Civil War 1936-1939.
We could talk for hours on end about this
war, but I’ll make just one point.
Italy, Germany and the Soviet Union all intervened
heavily, supporting opposing factions with
troops, weapons and money.
On the other hand, Britain and France simply
forbid the supply of arms to either side.
This non-interventionist policy was a continuation
of Baldwin’s plan not to alienate Mussolini’s
sympathies.
Yeah, it worked a treat (!).
From Appeasement to World War II
And now let’s zoom back to London, and fast
forward to the 3rd of September 1939.
Neville Chamberlain has just announced on
the radio that Great Britain is now at war
with Germany.
All his efforts to maintain peace in Europe,
were all vain in the end.
Chamberlain’s leadership during the war
is generally remembered as lacklustre at best
and lacking in initiative, being these the
months of the so called ‘Phoney War’,
in which French and British troops did little
but stand by the Maginot line, waiting for
a German attack.
However it is fair to recognise one important
victory which can be attributed to Chamberlain’s
foresight: the Battle of Britain, or the months
long duel in which the Royal Air Force established
air superiority over the Luftwaffe, thus preventing
Operation Sea Lion, the invasion of Great
Britain.
In the months after the Munich Treaty, Chamberlain
led the development of Britain’s air defence
systems, the more sophisticated in Europe:
it was thanks to him that the Royal Air Force
could rely on the revolutionary invention
of RADAR to coordinate wave after wave of
Spitfire fighter planes against incoming German
squadrons.
But Neville Chamberlain could not reap the
reward for such a success.
On the 10th of May 1940, after a failed attempt
to reclaim Norway from Nazi occupation, Chamberlain
resigned.
Winston Churchill – the main architect of
the Norwegian debacle – became the new Prime
Minister.
Chamberlain continue to serve in Churchill’s
cabinet, but resigned for good in October
1940, too ill with late stage bowel cancer.
Not one month later, on the 9th of November,
Chamberlain died in his estate near Reading,
in southern England.
Final words
As you have heard, it is too easy to dismiss
Neville Chamberlain as gullible and naïve
appeaser, who did not respond to Hitler’s
provocations for all the wrong reasons.
The reality was far more complex and it is
understandable how Appeasement may have been
considered as the best option at that time.
However, Chamberlain had a record for breaking
away with established policies and had he
listened to other opinions rather than the
Conservative majority, he could have changed
the course of history for the better.
Winston Churchill probably best summarised
the Czech crisis and Appeasement with one
of his most quotable lines, addressed to Chamberlain:
“You were given the choice between war and
dishonour.
You chose dishonour, and you will have war”